without Casablanca fans are renowned as
some of the most passionate and
organized in World football
they're famous for their so-called tfos
choreographed displays of support
involving huge banners and flags
over the last uh three weeks has been
nothing sort of spectacular open I
haven't seen anything Lucky in World
football
I can tell you that I've been to matches
you know in 10 11 different countries in
the world and I've never been to an
atmosphere like that I've downloaded an
app on my phone and tried to measure the
decibel level and it was around 90
decibels uh pretty consistently
throughout the match which I'm told is
pretty bad for your eardrums
[Applause]
without long history can be traced on
the walls of casablanca's old town but
only once before as the team played at
the club World Cup
the champions of Africa we are not
afraid of anyone playing in Morocco is
the big Advantage for us not just why
Dad fans but the whole country will be
behind the team
without's origin story is one that
informs the feelings this team inspires
and the French occupation access to
sports facilities was limited so in the
mid-1930s some Moroccans formed their
own club with Dad athletic began Life as
a water polo team but quickly expanded
to include football the side went on to
become a symbol of the Nationalist
movement whenever they played
Muhammad has supported the team all his
life for him where Dad will always be a
club that's about much more than just
winning trophies
why that is a source of Hope a source of
life it gives me a vision of a beautiful
world it's how I breathe how I forget
the problems of life after a week of
work I get to go on an adventure with my
love it's a love that can only be
understood by those who have grown up
with this club
football and resistance are with dad's
founding principles that Spirit has
produced a club that's ready to Take On
The World Andy Richardson Al Jazeera
Casablanca